коли біля чийогось Там невідомого
прізвища стояло позначка Z команда то
люди були готові голосувати за табуретку
я от сумно жартую що треба було свою
собаку вписати від неї було би більше
користі в тій самій Верховній Раді
замість окремих табуреток тому що
принаймні Моя собака Я думаю як і кожна
нормальна собака знає де господар де
рідна хата що треба слухатися команд
тобто законів України і що треба
захищати рідну хату коли біля чийогось
Там невідомого прізвища стояло позначка
з команда то люди були готові до
голосувати за табуретку я от сумно
жартую що треба було свою собаку вписати
від неї було би більше користі в тій
самій Верховній Раді замість окремих
табуреток тому що принаймні Моя собака Я
думаю як і кожна нормальна собака знає
де господар де рідна хата що треба
слухатися команд тобто законів України і
що треба захи